les patins
à 10 heures ce lundi matin le stand de
fabrice est désespérément vide plus un
seul trèfle du perche médaillé d'or au
salon de l'agriculture
victime de son succès et de la saison le
lait va d'abord aux chevaux qui naissent
en ce moment il ya eu des petits vic est
alors donc il y à tous les quinze jours
alors forcément des gens ils font leurs
leurs réserves parce qu'il aime bien et
puis bon c'est vrai qu'il est il est bon
pas trop cher et puis c'est ce qui
compte ce que nous c'est la qualité
actuellement on est un peu moins de lait
parce que les chefs vont leur petit et
donc faut attendre que ça remonte ce que
quand les chefs ont leurs petits pendant
une semaine on peut pas prendre le
relais
donc le lait on est on le donne aux
cochons en fait et puis bah après au
bout d'une semaine on pourra apprendre
le lait et puis après il faut attendre
15 jours pour avoir d'ennemis sec et
puis après un mois un mois et demi pour
avoir défait la direction villiers faux
ou corinne la femme de fabrice fabrique
le trèfle du perche fromage de chèvre au
lait d'alpine a fini 13 jours et salé au
sel cendrey cette médaille d'or pourrait
les aider à obtenir lee gp qu'il demande
depuis dix ans avec une dizaine d'autres
producteurs comme le trèfle ont d'une
certaine reconnaissance avec une
médaille eh ben ça va lui donner un
petit coup pouce parce qu'on est
finalement les deux producteurs avoir eu
des médailles un autre producteur dans
leur nord qui a eu une médaille de
bronze dans la catégorie e sandrine très
bas là on croise les doigts j'espère que
ça va marcher mais je pense qu'il faut
encore au moins un lot de 100 ans de
clients ils devront attendre encore une
dizaine de jours avant de pouvoir
acheter à nouveau du trèfle du perche et
pour cause c'est la saison des mises bas
200 chevaux naissent chaque semaine en
ce moment et le lait leur est réservé